estas son imágenes de los últimos
momentos del moskvá el buque insignia
militar de rusia el frente del barco
está en llamas se activaron las
mangueras contra incendios el barco se
hunde en el mar negro
para confirmar la autenticidad de las
imágenes se han comparado con varias
otras fotos del barco y coinciden la
embarcación militar rusa fue filmada
brevemente por los servicios de rescate
pero para el kremlin esto no es prueba
suficiente para confirmar que las
imágenes muestran su buque de guerra
ahora hundido
hemos visto las imágenes pero no podemos
confirmar su autenticidad
moscú sigue restando importancia a lo
sucedido alegando que una explosión de
municiones habría provocado un incendio
a bordo y no un misil antibuque
ucraniano neptune el lunes el ministerio
de defensa ruso publicó este vídeo según
los informes muestra alrededor de 100
sobrevivientes del barco hundido pero
todavía alrededor de 400 miembros de la
tripulación tienen un paradero
desconocido el padre de uno de los
tripulantes que sigue desaparecido no ha
tenido noticias de las autoridades sobre
el paradero de su hijo marinero del
barco compartió su enfado en facebook se
informó que toda la tripulación había
sido evacuada es mentira una mentira
descarada y cínica en una entrevista con
una periodista ruso independiente la
madre de un tripulante que sobrevivió al
hundimiento afirma que hay unos 40
muertos las autoridades rusas permanecen
en silencio en una llamada con el
hospital militar de sebastopol se
negaron a decir cuántas personas habían
resultado de heridas y la catedral de
sebastopol también ocultó información
no no hay una lista de muertos pero hay
mucha gente que ha desaparecido
a pesar de las crecientes llamadas de
las familias para obtener más
información sobre lo sucedido por ahora
sigue siendo un secreto de estado